Hey, what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and Oh,
just checking in on you.
Seeing how you weeks week's and Oh,
happy Valentine's Day to you.
Bobo Happy Valentine's Day to you.
Boom.
Bobo Happy Valentine's Day.
Dear lay
de [inaudible],
why don't want to you brave
strong warriors pick up the check.
You fuck in tight wads.
You know I was watching TV the other day
because I'm not a big reader, you know,
unless it's got a lot of pictures
and they sound out the words for me.
And there was this woman on TV,
right?
One of these daytime
talk shows assump shit.
She was just like Happy
Valentine's Day week. I sell,
I think we should celebrate the week.
It's a week of love.
It's just like how much free
shit are you trying to get?
It stopped back then. Like you're
celebrating love. You're not,
you celebrate and you yes.
Selfish.
Why is she a whore bill? Cause she's
on television. What? Too much makeup.
All right, let me, Jesus
Christ, why aren't you just
out there walking the block?
Um,
Oh man,
I'm in a grumpy ass fucking mood
cause I want to go to bed B to the
motherfucking Ed.
I want to go to bed bitches.
I don't know why I'm talking like a
fucking old white housewife right now who
watched a hip hop video,
but I am mother fuckers.
Um, I uh, yeah,
I want to go to bed, but I got to
go out and got to go run my hour.
I got to go run it because
I'm doing the special soon.
I've got to hit the comedy gym and all
I want to do is try out my new fucking
ideas. Right? That's what I want to
do. But I can't, I got to fucking dude.
I gotta I gotta be, I gotta be like,
you know, middle of 10th about it.
I know it's weird.
What I have to do is do my new
ideas and then start with a joke.
I'm going to fucking maybe start with
and then run the fucking shit and then in
the end I'm not going to do it.
I just need to be on stage talking.
That's all I need to do. Okay. I don't
know how these fucking people do it,
where they write the whole thing out, have
the whole thing memorized or whatever.
Um,
okay.
I don't know if it's, I'm lazy or
maybe that's not how my brain works.
I have no fucking idea. All I know is I'm
running it tonight and then that's it.
Then I'm coming home,
I'm going to bed and then a buck and
waking up the next day. I got it.
Table read for F is for
family episode four.
Fucking season has been great so far.
We get some new writers
and they're crushing it.
And um, I dunno, we're almost next week.
Next week we'll do four
or five maybe right there.
Then we'll be halfway through the
season already. And now you're thinking,
well shit, Bill, what's it
going to come out in June? Oh,
I mean just halfway through. Just the
first initial writing of it. Well,
how does it work, Bill? How would you
like to know how it works in case?
So you write the fucking thing, right?
And as you're writing the episodes,
they come back with something
that's known as an animatic.
An animatic is basically, it's just
basically black and white sketched.
And they're like, well, this is how
we're going to draw what you wrote.
Does this look good? And Mobility, like
we like this, don't have that chair there.
Have him stand up, have a move his arm
like this up and down when he says,
what the fuck is going on in here? Right.
You do that and then it comes back,
it's a little more drawn, a little more
color, you know, that's how it goes.
Just like that. But we're on the fourth
season so they know what we like,
we know what they like, so it moves
like last season moves along quickly.
So I'm hoping, uh, we'd
get this fucker done, um,
as soon as possible. So, uh, anyways, um,
then I'm going to take my lady
out for fucking Valentine's Day.
That's what I'm going to do.
And I'm going to try to be a nice guy
and try not got to get into a fight.
Try not to have any appeared yet.
MMM.
Yeah. I, you know what, I'm,
I'm doing so much shit right now
that I want to fucking go off on,
but I can't go off on it because
other people's lives will be affected.
You know what? Are you talking about?
Some top secret shit, Bill? No, I'm not.
I'm just talking about, you know, I dunno.
Just bullshit in my fucking life.
Like, uh, you would never know it,
but I am not in a good mood right now.
All right.
I'm not in a good fucking mood,
but I gotta do this.
I have responsibility to you.
Okay.
I answered the call 12 years
ago to start podcasting.
Okay.
The same way somebody answers the call
to defend the freedom of this country.
All right? Now, God damn it.
If white women in this country can
somehow enjoy white privilege and then yet
also make themselves
victims than God dammit,
I can put myself on the same
level as someone who's fighting,
you know, what are they saying?
They're doing it. They're
fighting for our freedom.
That's right.
Fighting for our freedom,
right?
As a podcast warrior,
living my truth,
I think I'm slowly going
insane. Um, anyways,
I don't have any advertising here.
I don't know what's going on.
So fucking podcast has been
going off the rails lately.
I'm not going to lie to you
and you don't want to think.
A lot of the biggest fucking problem is,
you know what the biggest
fucking problem is right now,
aside from the fact that I have no guest.
And then sitting here by myself,
you're listening to one of one of,
I'm like a [inaudible]
right now. Right? Uh,
the biggest fucking problem my life
right now is I'm sober. You know,
I don't know how the puck
of people do this shit.
I'm trying to think back to
my life before ever drank
because I had a hell of
a run. I went in, I went,
I didn't start drinking until
I was like 17, you know,
I had a couple sips of beer here or there,
but basically I spent the first
16 years of my life sober.
I don't know how I did it, but
I think back, I didn't have any,
there was no pressure now to
get up and do my paper route.
That was the biggest thing.
Occasionally it had to go collecting,
maybe it rained out in some of the
papers. Got Wet. Maybe there was that.
Maybe had a book report.
I mean those were the pressure days.
I wonder if kids over in Europe,
you know when they got a big book
report the next fucking day, you know,
after they give the book report,
do they drink like a fucking
couple of shots just to unwind,
you know,
cause there's just so much
more progressive over there
and they can allow their
kids to booze. I don't fucking
know. I don't know how it works.
I don't pretend to know. Um, but anyways,
I'm committed to this shit though.
I'm not drinking this year.
Okay.
Now I know those animals and Aa,
they tried to say you gotta go day to
day. All right? But they were different.
They were different group of people.
Okay.
All right.
If you ever think you an alcoholic,
go to an AA meeting and just listen
to the fucking stories and you know,
come out the other side and tell me
your as fucked up as those people.
I, I double dare you to
fucking do it. You know,
you're just come out of there
and be like, oh, you know,
I'm a fucking binge drinker. That's
what I am. You know what I mean?
Once I start losing teeth, you
know what? I kind of dial it back.
I'm not standing outside the fucking
liquor store waiting for it to open.
Yeah.
Fucking and mouthwash.
We go to an AA meeting.
You want to feel good about yourself?
You go to a fuck at AA meeting.
Just look at those fucking animals
just sitting there. God Damn.
Cigarette ashes. Fucking all
over the EDA. Yellow fingers.
Just shoven donuts down there.
Fucking pie holes done.
Unbelievable. Yeah. It's funny. I haven't
been in a, I went to two AA meetings.
What was it? One? Yeah,
to like 30 years ago.
Okay.
Well only cause the court told me I had
to um, it's a whole other fucking story.
Eli's got a tiller.
The stags dad get out gallery tag,
but I gave it a your fucking legs. His
back. All right, I'll go to these things.
And that was every fucking story.
They would say the most fucked
up shit ever jaw on the ground.
Like you gotta be fucking kidding me.
How did you live through that?
And then right after that, and they'd
be like, and then the craziest thing is,
you know I want to do
is have another drink.
Oh, Jesus Christ. I love
making fun of alcoholics.
I really do. Alcoholics, feminists.
Who else?
The Obamas.
I was fucking people.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know what fucking deal with
the devil did they sign that they just
fucking get off Scott fucking free out
there with all that corporate money
hanging out of their fucking pockets.
Everybody out here is looking at him
like they're fucking, I dunno what.
MMM.
Anyways, I, why do I talk politics?
I don't pay attention to it.
Every time I start to look at it, it,
it just fucking, uh, I don't know.
It either bores me to tears or
scares the shit out of me. You know?
It's either like somebody filibustering
on the fucking floor or it's like,
I dunno, you just watched them,
you know,
building up a new candidate.
And so much of it has nothing
to do with their message.
It has to do with way the way they look.
Uh,
you know,
it goes back to Clinton.
He played the saxophone on fucking our
Cineo this watershed fucking moments in
politics that changes it
forever. You know, like, uh,
as far as the age of television,
you had Nixon sweating sitting
there like a fucking catcher.
You know what John F. Kennedy was all
tanned up with this fucking legs crossed.
You know,
like he was hanging out at a fucking
country club and people who listen to the
debate said Nixon won. And people who
watched it said, Kennedy won. You know,
Nixon with his sweaty upper lip.
MMM.
Yeah. That was it. That was a moment.
Michael Dukakis sticking his head out
of that fucking tank. That was a moment.
Bill Clinton playing the saxophone
and then I would say,
uh,
Donald Trump,
this last one where he didn't really
debate as much as he just sort of trash he
just sorted was doing a roast.
MMM.
That's what I want to see just as a
standup comic is how are People gonna
fucking debate.
That guy,
you know,
takes me back to like, when Patrice was
alive, we just couldn't beat the guy.
So you'd literally walked down to the
comedy cellar and I would have like
fucking four insults.
I would just be thinking about his face
was something I saw him do on stage and
I would have like four
fucking insults ready to go,
you know,
just so I could get to the table and
sit down and order some fucking food.
I feel like Trump,
you got to do the same thing.
Like
Hillary should have just abandoned,
you know,
whatever fucking horse shit
she was going to say. Right.
And just fucking attack
this to pay, you know, and,
and just this stupid look on his face and
should have just sat there and imitate
it. She should just fucking,
uh, I believe that the, the,
the youngsters call it clowned him.
He should,
he should've just trashed them back.
Um,
I dunno, that was such a fascinating
fucking thing to see happen.
There was all these fucking rules and he
just came in there like a God damn bull
in a China shop and traipsed
right through all of it.
And those people all had no answer.
All those years I watched those debates
in these fucking guys running the
debates,
acting like they had this fucking control
that if you fucking broke these rules,
that something was gonna
happen, that there was some
sort of repercussion for it.
So no one ever did for the most part.
You know,
they talk a little bit over their time.
Trump completely fucking ignored
all of them. And when he did,
they had nothing.
Absolutely fucking nothing.
So I dunno, what does he like? He said,
only two years in little over two years.
Okay.
So you've got this year, you got next
year and then the show starts again.
What do you guys think?
Let's fucking handicap this
like a football.
It's the beginning of the season.
Who Do you think's gonna win the super
like how I wanna know how you guys,
even if you were into Donald Trump,
cause the guy,
he's a fascinating fucking
problem in a debate
cause it's like this guy is just like,
his style is so fucking not what there
you all of these fucking politicians,
unless they hosted a reality show,
maybe that's his strength.
He didn't take the bait in classes so he
doesn't know that you just fucking goes
in, you know? I Dunno.
I found it as a standup comedian.
Fascinating.
Okay.
Mikey was this heckler that
you just couldn't get. I
can't shut them. Like I just,
when I looked at all
those other candidates,
they would like these comedians
and they were facing this Hackler.
Yeah,
that was just funny oven then the comic
on stage or just wouldn't shut up and
there was no security.
They couldn't shut them the fuck up.
Okay.
The only other time I
saw something like that,
I saw bill O'Reilly when he went on the
view and he just said whatever the fuck
he wanted and he made them so mad.
Two of them got up and left and he was
literally two fucking hosts away from
hosting the I O'Reilly factor
on the fucking view, you know?
But Babs was fucking old school.
Okay.
And she called the ladies back in.
She's like, what are we doing here?
Sit the fuck back down.
You know,
it's just a man in a shirt
saying things relax. Okay.
And they all fucking relaxed and
then that was it. Um, anyways,
I love when they walked out too.
Like that meant something like I'm getting
up and walking out like all of show
business was going to, was
going to stop. You know,
I dunno.
I don't know what the fuck's
been going on with me lately,
but this is maybe my thought,
like if I've learned anything in my 50
years on this planet is nobody gives a
shit.
Yeah.
Occasionally when somebody
gives a shit, they, they, it's,
it's so fucking rare that they actually
will do like a piece about it on the
news.
Like we found somebody that gives a shit.
We found somebody who
doing the right thing,
this is what they do and
they're doing it the right way.
Why is my voice cracking?
You know,
where they make a
documentary about somebody.
There's so few people doing
good things. I feel that they actually,
that's why they created the documentary.
So it came about, it's like, why don't
we just make a movie about this person?
Well,
now that there's such a good person,
like it's not going to come
off as a believable movie.
You literally have to fucking film this
guy or this woman doing this nice shit.
So anybody believes it,
right?
Ah, am I dreaming this podcast right
now? Is this podcast actually happening?
I have no idea.
I watched a little bit of the Bruins
and a little bit of the Celtics.
I've decided that, uh, at some point
I do have to put my foot down a little
bit and take a little bit of control of
the TV. You know, my daughter's
just so adorable. It's hard for me
to a, you know, say no, but
I know I have to write. So,
you know,
last night the Bruins were playing
the Black Hawks, so it's just like,
I just want to watch one period of hockey.
I'll watch third period of hockey,
you know,
so I got to put the TV on and
I really try not to, you know,
do the screen time thing
with my kid. Uh, I, I,
I believe in that whole
thing that having them,
especially with smartphones and all
that shit, it's just, it's fucking,
I don't think it's good for him initially.
Uh,
and I'm basing that on shit. I've
overheard other people say, um,
not to mention last weekend when the TV
wasn't on and I didn't have my phone and
I just took out a deck of cards and I
just had a great fucking time, I was like,
Oh yeah, remember that? Looking at
another person and connecting with them.
MMM.
Anyways, I, uh, the fuck
is my point here. Oh yeah.
So I got to put on the hockey game
and the second the TV goes on,
she starts yelling out her shows,
you know,
made me mouse Minnie. Right.
I'm like, no, no many miles.
She went to bed many miles, went
to bed, then she does this crying.
Yeah.
You know, just forcing it out. And I'm
like, we're going to watch hockey. Yeah.
Be thinks she sees now that sports, she
goes, football, football. I'm like, no,
hockey, hockey. So Chico was
upset for a little bit, but then,
then she was cool. And then, uh,
tonight I put on the Celtics and
then she pointed the TB. She's like,
hockey, hockey. I'm like, no
basketball. So then she, you know,
said basketball,
we watch sat a little bit,
but then she wanted to do the alphabet.
So I put it on mute and I was doing the
alphabet with her and then she was kind
of looking at the TV. So I said,
fuck it. And I shut it off.
And it just did the whole,
you know, a apple B bad.
See cupcake d,
dinosaur raw.
I forget what he is, you know, and I
go through the whole fucking thing. Um,
anyways.
Um,
so now I'm sitting here.
It's Wednesday night.
I'm doing this fucking podcast
cause tomorrow is Valentine's Day.
And uh,
I have to somehow stay awake.
It fucking go out and go do my
spot tonight. Roma God damn hour.
All I gotta do is just get behind the
wheel of the car and that'll wake me up.
I'll stick my head out the window like
fucking ace Ventura pet detective.
I'm run down to this little
fucking hole in the wall.
I'm gonna run my fucking set and then
that'll be it. I'll be good. But with,
the thing is,
is I've been getting up,
I've been going to the fucking gym again
in the morning. All right. And I slowly,
I'm to the point where my shoulder is
strong enough where I'm almost to the
point I could do a dip after this rotator
cuff fucking nightmare is finally I,
I, I did, I did it so fucking wrong.
I kept babying my shoulder still.
I had that frozen shoulders shit.
Right now I've had to go all the way
back and I just keep having setbacks.
But what I finally learned is when I go
on the road and I can't go to the gym
when I come back,
okay,
I can't pick up where I left, left off
and I can't even just go five pounds down.
I have to go 15 pounds down or
this thing flares up against.
So I finally figured that out. So now
I'm to the point where I take the dip,
the dip bar, he can adjust
it all the way down. So on.
Basically my feet are on the floor and
I'm just sort of bending my legs doing
the dipping motion. So now I've got it
to the point where I'm just sort of,
you know when Michael Jackson would come
up on his toes, I'm kind of like that.
So I'm supporting most
of the weight of my legs,
but more and more the upper
body is going to support it.
I got to tell you the day
I fucking do a dip then.
I know I'm getting close and
I've been doing, I disguise,
sent me an about some shoulder exercises
and I've been doing this thing where I
just sort of hang from the chin up bar,
you know, with my feet on the ground.
But every day I do a little more of
the upper body holding the weight,
you know,
incrementally ever so fucking slowly.
And then I think eventually,
um,
the person I'm working with is
telling me because of my body weight,
I need to basically be able to do the
lat pull down machine like 120 pounds,
three reps of 15. And when I do that,
then I can attempt to do a pull up without
fucking up my rotator cuff and starting
all over again. It's been a long,
slow fucking road
for an old bastard like myself.
Um,
but anyways,
I am very excited about slash
apprehensive about doing this.
Uh, this special coming
up. I just, I fucking,
this is the part that I hate is having
to be disciplined because like tonight I
would just go down,
I've just fucking go off and I have to
go down and actually work and I'm a lazy
fucker so I don't, I don't like working
and being a big God damn baby about it.
But I'm going to go down,
I'm going to fucking get it done.
And then next week everybody, uh, is
the Patrice O'neil comedy benefits.
So I'm going to be in New York City
doing that benefit. The next night.
Wednesday I'm actually going to be
doing nine o'clock show at Caroline's on
Broadway. I've not headlined there and
probably a decade. And that is the,
the first place that headline
to me in New York City,
they used to have to pull the curtain
and I would draw like 30 or 40 fucking
people, anybody that could
drag off of Times Square.
MMM.
And that's when me,
Patrice Norton,
mmm.
Everyone from my graduating class was
just starting to like close out a show on
a unlike a Tuesday night or whatever. Man,
it's a really cool thing.
So it kind of takes me back to
all of all of those times. So, um,
uh, and then I think I'm in New
York for the rest of the week,
so I'll be bouncing around doing spots
all around the city, just stay in shap.
And then I go out from New York,
I'm going straight over to Great Britain,
and then I just bang out
about five or six shows there.
And then I do,
uh,
I do two nights at Royal Albert
Hall on the fourth and the fifth,
and I knock this fucker out.
And after that,
oh,
all this fucking crazy political talk
and all this negative shit that I've been
doing right now,
it's just because I'm under the pressure.
Don't even fucking listen to me.
Okay.
The world is not as bad as I'm fucking
saying it is. I just, you know,
I just got to get on the other side
of this fucking thing. And once I do,
then I'm good finish.
Right.
And the rest to f is for family and then
the rest of my year is just opened up.
And then it's my favorite
favorite fucking time,
right after a special,
you have no fucking act.
And I get to go on stage
and just fucking bomb.
It's my favorite thing in the
fucking world. And then also be like,
I don't have to put out another special
for a couple of years. This is beautiful.
Oh, gives a shit. If I'm doing a
fucking Ronald Reagan impression.
Oh, I did the ice house the other
night. I had a fucking last night.
Ran The hour out there.
What are the fuck I did. Um,
had a great time out there.
Okay.
You know,
worked with Bart.
Nick fucking Joe to Rosa J K to braid it.
Can't pray them.
Um,
trying out some new shit.
I always have to try out the new shit.
I can't just like do my fucking act.
I swear to God. Then I feel like
I'm doing my God damn taxes. Um,
so anyways, so you know what, let's
look up some fucking headline, right?
And quit listening to me talking about me.
I got to start having more
guests on this fucking show.
I think I've exhausted everything. I can
fucking talk about about myself here.
All right, here we go. Oh, look at
that. I'm looking at UK openers.
This is, uh, Ian So-and-so.
This is a fucking something, something,
something. All right, Google,
Google news. All right, let's see
what's going on here. Oh, by the way,
you know something? I just
saw the original, you know,
the original intellectual fucking
children's book, chicken little,
you know that stupid God damn.
Uh,
the fuck is it that, that God damn chicken
nae acorn falls on his head. He says,
the sky's falling. He runs around
and gets everybody off. You know,
got all in a fucking panic
original chicken little story.
Okay.
And I got to type in Fox.
The original chicken little
was a story called Henny penny.
All right? Now chicken little, I don't
even know how that fucking story ended,
but it didn't end up with anybody fucking
dying. But in Henny penny chicken,
little has an acorn falls on
his fucking head and, and uh,
whatever. Yeah, Henny penny. Any
penny had a fucking blah, blah, blah.
And then he runs into ducky Faqih
and he said, yeah, the sky's falling.
And then Ducky funky in Henny penny went
up to and went to fucking Loosey Goosey.
And then they, the sky's
falling. And then Lucy Goosey,
fucky Douggie and Henny penny.
That's how they do it, right?
It's every fucking bird
you could possibly,
God damn eat freaking out that
the fucking sky has fallen.
And then they run into a fox,
the Fox like, hey man, what do you
guys all freaking out about it?
Any Penny Ducky Faqih and, uh,
the, the fucking Loosey Goosey.
I'll go other. The Sky's falling. Jesus
Christ. And he goes, Oh, you know what?
I live in a cave. Come on over
here and we'll fucking be safe.
And then the story just ends with the
Fox in his little fucking Fox cubs,
whatever you call them,
with big smiles on their faces,
cause they fucking hate him.
That's how it ended.
That was the original. And, uh,
people were saying that
it was too, um, you know,
to fucking dark or whatever the
fuck it was. But, uh, you know,
so I have a theory about those old
original or some of the old stories like,
or Disney shit like Bambi and why
the parents die and all that shit.
You know why that is?
Why it was so fucking dark back then.
Cause people fucking died.
People were hungry.
He had to go out and kill an animal. You
didn't just go down to fucking, you know,
Goddamn Ralph's and get a chicken breasts.
You had to kill that fucking thing.
Watch it, flap it's wings for the
last time. Take out the end trails,
be covered in blood and all of that shit.
It was a fucking gory mess.
People got tuberculosis,
they got fucking, uh,
they got a polio. All kinds of
horrible shit happened back then.
They had gross on their goddamn faces.
It was fucking difficult.
So that was probably a cute story.
Do you know, cause they knew so much about
wildlife back then, like, yeah, you know,
the Fox, the Fox is fucking
smart man. You know,
I have no idea.
I don't know.
I just find that fascinating that you
know nowadays if you'd do that. Oh my God,
that's gonna fucking, there'll
be a tragedy. Oh, look at
those converse all stars.
Please have at my size. They got,
they brought the old doctor Jay back.
Please have my size. How does the
Internet? No, all right. There it is.
Oh, there's an ad. Let me see. Then they
got my size. They never have my size.
It's always fucking sold out
of.
So why did they wait so long to bring
the old fucking doctor Jay Leather
Converse all star back. It's such a clean
look and fucking sneaker. All right.
All sizes. What do you
got? What do you got?
They got my size.
Get the fuck Outta here.
All right, I'll fucking buy
it. I'm going to click on buy.
Here's how it work. Make a
bid. Make an author. Hey,
here's how it worked. Fuck you.
Sneakers. How about
that? You costs the fuck.
Was that all about you want this
sneaker? We have your size. All right,
I'll buy it. All right. Here's
how it works. What do you
mean this is how it works.
All right, let's get back to the
fucking news here or get to the news.
I haven't got to Google maps is using
giant virtual arrows to stop people from
getting lost. Jesus fucking how much
was can they help you with this thing?
Oh is my new pet peeve.
You know,
you and you scroll past the fucking
video they want you to watch and then it
just goes down with you stalking you.
Um, anyways, here we go.
Google maps wants to make it easier for
people to find their way to busy urban
spaces and it thinks large cartoon arrows
can help is when you're walking down
the street related article.
How Alexa knows the difference between
a breaking window in a wine glass.
Oh Jesus.
Should I just embrace this shit?
So I just bring this robot bitch into
my fucking house now, Tommy a bench.
Uh, all right. On Monday,
Google Max begin maps began letting
some users test a new augmented reality
feature and it's mobile app that shows
graphics such as highlighted Arrows and
street names floating in midair over
a live view from their camera on their
smartphone screens.
It's meant to help them navigate city
streets that Jesus Christ could there be a
more boring fucking article.
What kills me is that there's an entire
generation of kids that get excited by
this.
MMM.
Alright.
Deck of cards with my face on it.
Okay. This is more
exciting to me. All right.
Custom photo cards. Oh, he
can actually do this shit
and fucking take a picture.
My God damn nuts.
Um,
of course it's a mother hugging her child.
Who the fuck's gonna put that
on a deck of cards. This cards,
these things are dirty. They're
filthy. People lose money. All right.
They lose relationships with these things.
Let's let the luckiest deck of cards
you ever going to design. Wait a minute,
wait a minute. Let me,
let me look this up here.
Uh,
Bose picture deck of cards is
what kills me is fucking stupid.
Is this, is this is going to
actually hit something right in.
Someone's going to have already done this.
Yeah.
All right. Here we go. Images.
Yeah,
just here for the booze.
So we got that on their fucking cards,
unlike a chocoholic but for booze.
So give me,
it all comes back to booze.
Just here for the booze.
Yeah.
Let's, let's, I think that's
something else I like to do.
I like to just Google search asshole
things are al Ko holics just week.
All my God, somebody said,
are they selfish apps?
A fuckin lutely are alcoholic.
Selfish. Here we go. Let's,
let's read this trashy,
a deeper look at wa into why
alcoholics are so selfish.
It's a disease man.
Um,
all right.
Many people seem to think that addicts
and alcoholics are quite selfish,
especially when they're using, oh,
did they? Do they fucking get me here?
That they're not going
to say they're selfish?
Chances are if you had a loved
one who was in an active,
active addiction,
we've,
we'd like to invite all active
addicts to board next, please.
Then you've experienced the selfishness
of an addict firsthand. MMM,
no, I'm talking about just
like even when they're dry.
Yeah.
We'll, we'll all recovering
alcoholics become less
selfish, unfortunately. No. Oh,
I love this site.
Not all recovering alcoholics will be
willing to address their selfishness.
In reality,
there will be some super selfish people,
including narcissists that we'll
continue to being self. Well, I mean,
they could say that about anybody,
right? I'm just being a dick.
Are Alcoholics
weak?
This is actually fun searches to just
search shit that's alcoholics are not
powerless. Human weakness
behind alcoholism. Uh,
it's not a good one.
Let's,
let's one last search here
and then I gotta wrap this up.
Are Most fem and this fem,
I can't even spell it.
Feminists dumb.
It's not feminist to pour bleach
on man spreaders. It's just stupid.
Whoa. Jesus. Were they doing that?
Why anti-feminism is a logical,
evil and incredibly unsexy.
Well, I want to be sexy.
I thought being a feminist meant I
couldn't wear lipstick or crave men with
small behinds. I thought that, oh my God.
Can you imagine actually clicking on
that? Why the fuck would I read that? Uh,
why did,
why what teen did to her teacher?
What team did when her teacher said
not to be a feminist, to people?
Just make these stories up.
The results of this may surprise you.
All right? It's not feminist to pour
bleach on man's spiders is just stupid.
Okay.
I had no idea that that bothered
women's so much to just sit there.
It's like we got dick and balls. We
have stuff hanging off of us. You know,
you've got to make some room
there. Um, it's an all tucked away,
all nice and fucking tidy.
Like your shit. I'm all right.
Feminist and does not deserve to be
undermined by idiotic acts that set men
against women. Oh my God.
God bless this woman now.
He is a nice rational fucking
person he could talk to.
This is my new video manifesto dedicated
to the problem of man's spreading,
the disgusting act that is being fought
with around the world and it is hushed
up in us.
Yeah.
Men demonstrating their alpha manhood
in the subway with women and children
around it has nothing to do with that,
which is sitting there.
You built the whole backstory.
Like you're sitting there,
look at my dick and balls.
I will take up as much space
as I want with my privates.
Um, if you quickly show
what kind of macho you are,
we will publicly cool you off.
This video manifesto was created in
the assistant with friends who share my
position. I guess this is, I
guess it's a video of a woman.
Okay.
Pouring bleach on guys.
All right. Anyways,
did you hear the one about the Russian
student who was so fed up with man
spreading that she took to the subways
of Saint Petersburg to sprayed the
alluded bleach on men's
crutches? Hilarious. Right?
I got to admit,
that's fucking funny.
And this woman says wrong.
Look,
I hate man spreading as much as
the next unreasonable feminists.
It's antisocial.
It's rude.
It's displays an arrogant disregard
for this people sitting around you.
It's behavior that women
just wouldn't get away with.
What are they talking about?
You use the fucking men's room.
Okay.
The line is too long in the
ladies from you use the mat.
You have no respect for our
personal space. These fucking women,
they're out of their fucking minds.
I'm not saying they don't
have some legitimate bitches,
but the way they're acting like
they're not doing anything wrong.
It's just fucking, anyway, so let's,
let's, let's read a little more.
Okay.
And to be clear,
I don't mean that I'm advocating for men
sitting with their legs clamp together,
lady. I don't give a fuck what you're,
what you're acting like you're, you're,
you're
okay.
You,
you're like,
you've got some sort of legal legislation
here that just got passed and then I
have to adhere to this anyways.
I don't eat, I don't either,
unless I'm wearing a short skirt.
Nor am I insisting that men should cross
their legs at all times. Oh, thank you.
Thank you for that.
And that existing,
that the existence of their penis
is no barrier to doing this.
Some may say crossing the,
some men say crossing the legs is fine.
Some men say it isn't not
having a penis myself,
I don't feel the position to be the
final arbitrator on this pressing matter.
Uh, this is not a, this is one of
the, this is just like, you know,
global warming.
Who gives a fuck about that?
Corporations dictating our foreign policy.
Who gives a about this men trying
to sit comfortably on the subway.
Um, anyways, I think
that's the end of the pot.
Just this was a very weird podcast,
but you know what it did?
It got me to within two hours
of when I have to go on,
I got to late in that spot tonight.
[inaudible] I'm an old man.
Oh Buddy.
Oh don't dope.
Mandy's Biondi sitting in the fucking
rain to do toto me undies me undies.
They're nice and soft.
So there is no pain.
Robin on your balls from
the left and the right,
you're gonna sleep all fucking night
cause your balls as soft with fucking me
undies.
Unlike those tidy whities hate your balls.
All right, I'm going to fucking car right
now. I'm parked. I'm doing this safely.
Mandy's, ask yourself one
fucking important question.
Is your underwear making you
happy at this very moment?
What a question to ask on Valentine's
Day or were you not thinking about your
underwear?
What'd you like to be wearing?
Underwear that is so soft that you feel
like you're making love to an actual
cloud all day long. Ah, Jeez.
You fucking the hemisphere there.
Well, I've got one word
for you. Me undies.
Not only will you feel like your
loins are being hugged by joy itself,
but me undies gives you multiple style
options for both men and the fucking
ladies. Choose between classic
colors too adventurous, prince,
prince like significant otters,
plant babies and shamrocks.
Speaking of Prince,
why not match your bottom half with your
better half and get a matching prince
for you and your partner?
Me,
he says a great offer for my listeners
for any first time purchasers,
you order me undies,
you get 50 15% one five
15% off and free shipping.
This is a no brainer.
Get 15% off a pair of the most comfortable
undies you will ever put on to get
all to get your 50% off your first
fucking Pythia free shipping and a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash
bird that's m e d, u, n d,
I e s.com/burr.
Oh look who it is.
Dollar Shave Club. Dude,
what the fuck's with their
hair on your face there?
Dollar Shave Club has
everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best and you
never have to go to the store again.
That's because they deliver everything
you need right to your dealer and they
help. They keep your fully stocked
on what you use so you don't run out.
Here's how it works.
Dollar Shave Club has everything
you need to get ready no matter.
You just fucking said this.
How, how's that? Okay.
They haven't this new program where they
automatically keep you stocked up on
all your products you use. You determine
what you want and when you want it,
and it shows up right at your door from
once a month to once every six months,
however you want to do it. Plus there's
a handsome discount. The more you buy,
the more you save. And Right now dollar
shave club has a bunch of status sets.
You can try for just five bucks
like their oral care. After that,
the restock box ships regular
sized products at regular,
at a regular price.
Get your status set for just $5 right
now@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr that's
dollar shave club.com/burr
oh all my favorites here. Butcher
block, butcher box, my favorite,
I can't even say it puts your box,
delivers healthy 100% grass fed
and grass finished beef free range.
Organic chicken and heritage breed pork,
not bread.
Heritage breed pork,
so tasty.
The incredible quality and put your
box meets starts with the commitment to
raising animals humanely and
free of antibiotics and hormones.
Listening to the feminist manifesto
before they're slaughtered,
Cook with p the peace of mind knowing you
are eating healthy, high quality meat.
Each box comes at least two with at
least eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual
size meals. You fat fucks.
She get 24 meals out of that, you can
choose from five different box types.
All beef, beef and chicken,
beef and pork mixed box.
We ain't about that around here.
You stay with your own, uh,
custom box lets you choose your own cuts.
My favorite cut of meat is
the heritage breed pork. Oh,
you do that? A little bit
of mashed potatoes, right?
A little bit of fucking
all natural Gornick or,
or going organic fucking apple sauce.
Sear it on both sides.
Finish it in the oven.
Take it out with a little rosemary
garlic, Beth butter Beth, oh Jesus.
But two picks,
two free filet minions,
Free Bacon and $20 off your order.
Jesus Christ.
Go to butcher box.com/burr and enter Bert.
Check checkout go.
Now this is over a $50 value and
available for a limited time.
This makes me want to sign up
for it again to free Philemon,
yawns and Free Bacon. This is a
company then understands America.
Put your box.com/burr and
enter burr at checkout. Okay.
Thank you for [inaudible].
You're listening
to this absolute fucking bullshit
of a podcast. Um, I'm actually
having, um, oh, I haven't,
I have a big guest coming on
for the Monday morning podcast.
Uh, I got Jason Reitman who I was lucky
enough to work with on the front runner.
And, um, that movie is coming on
to all the streaming services.
I believe maybe today it came on or,
or sometime soon.
So Jason was nice enough to agree.
I asked them,
come on the podcast so he could
come on and promote that movie. Um,
it's one of my favorite things that
I've done. So we're going to talk that,
we're going to talk movies,
he's going to be,
I think directing the next ghostbuster
movie and all that type of stuff.
So that's
what I'm going to have for you on
Monday. And, um, other than that,
we've got a little bit
of music here and uh,
after that we'll have another half
hour of a throwback Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday morning
podcasts. God bless all of you,
especially all the strong brave
women who listened to this. Um,
without you, the world would
be nothing. Okay. And I'm
closing my legs as I fucking
hit stop on my recorder.
Six
days.
You know, I was bitching about Valentine's
Day. You know, I always tease you about,
you know, how we go out to
celebrate our relationship. Yeah.
Except I pay by the way. How, how much
fun was it going out on the [inaudible]?
It was really nice. It was great.
Yeah. Doing that from now on. Right.
It was still going to be our nice, quiet,
romantic. Yup. There was none of the hype.
We went to a really nice place. Not
going to lie. It wasn't actually cheap,
but I can't imagine what that would've
caught. We would've been standing outside.
Oh yeah.
You know,
you and your little glitter dress
looking at the other girls in there.
Glitter dress is going to you like
my glitter tries as much as her,
I should have gotten mine in poofy
shoe shoe colors. Um, so anyways,
so I've been bitching about the
ladies on this thing, right?
Like what do you guys do?
And they're talking about
this stake in a blow job day.
Yes, yes, yes, yes,
yes. All right. I like it.
I'll tell you when you were in heaven,
when not only can they not, can't say it.
Yeah.
When they're,
when they're proficient in both of those
categories because there's a lot of
people out there, they're
going to say, all right,
steak in a blow job day and one of
them is it going to be up to snuff?
And there is,
there is a prevailing attitude amongst
women that they are just automatically
good in bed because they're there and
there's the prevailing attitude that men
don't know what's going on. We
don't know what's going on. Well,
we already think it is. We're just
happy to be here. It's a privilege,
which is why this lady could says
the Valentine's Day, this is,
this is from a lady. She said, hey bill,
I heard what you were saying about women
and Valentine's Day and how we don't
buy our men gifts and we expect
the whole day to be about us. Well,
here's what I did from my
husband. Uh, by the way,
I'm honestly not trying to sell
you anything. He goes, I, she goes,
I bought him the liberator
Wedge Ramp Combo set. Uh,
what's that?
You might ask,
I actually know about this
from the opiate Anthony show.
They refer to it as a bedroom,
as bedroom, adventure gear.
It's a set of cushions designed to help
you achieve more positions during sex as
well as deeper penetration. So
no, we didn't go out to dinner.
No stupid cards were exchanged. We
simply stayed home and fucked all night.
So you can choke on that.
You douche. I love your bill.
Go Fuck Yourself. I like this girl. Yeah,
but you know what's funny about that
as she's patting yourself on the back,
she bought something for herself.
It's for both of them. No, it isn't.
What do you mean it isn't she
going to do with it without him?
I don't need deeper penetration.
That's for you. That is wealthy again,
that's, that's the difference.
What is the difference? She know.
I'm not saying that led guys don't
satisfy their women properly, that they,
that their dick isn't big enough.
I'm not talking about that.
I'm talking about how she's
patting herself on the back.
Like she went out and bought this guy,
the NFL package for next season.
Like she actually went out
and bought something for him.
She didn't at the very least
she bought something for them.
But the real thing about that,
that's for the woman so he can hit it at
that angle that you like so he can hit
your spot so he can get in there
deeper. Guys, you don't appreciate that.
I'm not saying I don't appreciate it
and I'm not saying it's not a great
invention,
but what I'm saying is she's acting
as though like this was some sort of a
sacrifice that she basically bought him
something that would get her better Dick
and she's patting herself on the
back for it. It's fucking ridiculous.
I think it's clever.
It is clever because she's acting as
though she did something but she didn't
see this is it.
This is the thing about that is the
genius of women is you guys act like sex
doesn't feel good for you too.
You Act like you guys allowing
us to have sex with you,
like you don't want it and like this is
like you like waxing a floor and it's
just a big fucking pain in the ass.
You know,
she got some in that and that is like
celebrate story of their relationship as
opposed to like the typical dinner.
It's like it's about our intimacy.
It's about our connection. So why don't
we get something that will enhance that?
Yeah,
but this is the thing.
I got to go out and buy you like
some necklace or some let me go.
How do I get to wear it?
I got to take you out to dinner.
Celebrate and I pay for
the whole fucking thing.
It's all about the guy going out,
spending money on you,
getting you shit that you want,
and it's the precious for the
guy to show his love to you. Oh,
I know a white guy who can
dunk a basketball. All right,
let's stop talking about the exceptions.
I'm talking about the fucking rule here.
All right? Okay. You know what
I'm saying? Yes I do. Okay.
Alright. Right there we
go. This tapping out.
Fucking tapping out. Why?
Why? Why Do Women Act like
sex doesn't feel good to them?
Why do you, why do you, why do you guys,
can you please talk into the microphone?
I'm not like that, so I don't
know. I couldn't tell you.
You don't have any insight. I can't keep
this going. All right, let's keep going.
I don't really know. Women that are
like, Oh God, it's such a chore.
Like maybe in next 10 years when I was
making men will be complaining about that.
I Dunno, but, well, when I was making
fun of Valentine's Day this weekend,
some girl in the crowd was going
like, you know what? I said,
well what did you do for it? And she
goes, she, he got to hit this and
yeah.
Yeah.
What can I just show up and be like,
hey, you get to suck this lady.
Never. This is you. Yeah. Never.
You never get to do that, right?
No, but I don't want it. Is the
planning about this, what it is,
if guys could ever stop being such
fucking sluts and giving it a well,
that's why women women don't respect Dick
is because it's so easy for him to get
it. If you'd stop giving it away, if,
if every guy would just start
the day and fucking rub one out,
right world would be a lot more peaceful
at least until two in the afternoon.
By then your balls fill up again.
You start getting competitive wise,
his cubicle bigger than mine. Um, I
don't even know what I'm saying here.
It's just, it's, you know what it is?
It's just one of those things
that balances it out, right?
I could choke slam you on the floor
and you could cut off the sex and that
balances out,
but it's illegal for me to hit you.
But for some reason it's not
illegal for you to cut off the sex.
And that right there people is
what's known as the tipping point.
And that's how you lose.
Yep.
Hi
Barry.
Hey,
what's going on?
It is gopher and it is the Monday
morning podcasts for Monday,
February 14th,
2011 happy Valentine's Day. You Bunch, uh,
FEGS the fuck is wrong with you,
Huh?
Oh,
you douchebags out there buying flowers
and fucking candy at cvs that isn't
love. Ah, you bunch of fucking sheep.
What are you doing?
The fuck is wrong with you.
Somebody ought to know where it tells
you this is the day you got to go.
Tell that fucking pain in the ass that
you love her. What she doing for you?
Ah, she paying for dinner tonight?
Did she have to go make reservations?
What the fuck is she going
to do other than get ready?
I got news for you. She's not
doing a fucking thing. All right,
so why don't you save yourself some money?
Pick a fight with their today.
All right, anything she
says. So you'd just be like,
that's what this is what I'm talking
about. And then just storm out,
you know,
and just let her leave 40 messages.
You're not picking up and it's
scaring me. Okay? Just let's,
let's work it out and
just wait till tomorrow.
Just wait till tomorrow. It's plenty
of reservations at fucking candy.
75% off.
Come on people.
Come on fellas. You're better than this.
You're better than this. Don't get,
don't get sucked into this
stupid ass fucking holiday.
I know what you're thinking. Well,
what are you going to do? Work to fuck?
I'll tell you what the fuck I'm doing.
I sat down at a nice mature conversation
with my Horman and I said, listen,
this is fucking stupid.
All right.
There's every restaurant's
going to be packed. You know,
would you care for the heavily sheer
golf for $900 he went out and my,
can I just grab your fucking waiter face
and just shove it in something, right.
Gadget, whatever. You
know what I'm saying?
I actually worked it out with
my girl this year, said, listen,
I'll take you out on the 15th all right,
I'll take you to a nice fine restaurant
where there'll be plenty of goddamn
tables.
You know,
there won't be some sad fucking
immigrant with flowers coming by with an
accordion every five seconds, you
know, she's taking the night off.
We could sit there and actually enjoy
the Goddamn meal for Ra, you know,
only 30% markup as opposed to 200%
what I'm trying to save people is,
uh, if you want to find out if
you're with someone who's cool, Leah,
just see if they'll celebrate Valentine's
Day on like the 16th or the 15th,
you know,
it's like Vegas go there right after
the new years when new year when
everybody's fucking broke.
That's when you go,
you get a hotel room for like seven
bucks. Oh yeah. I'm telling you,
go on fucking orbits. You
think I'm lying to you? Um,
whatever. What do you,
what do you get it? I just,
I hate this holiday. All
right. I'm not a fan of love.
So this holiday annoys the
shit out of me and you know,
fans of my podcast should realize too. I
flip out like this on flag day. I don't,
I don't care if you have a flag. I don't
know. I don't have a problem with it.
You know why?
Cause there's no fucking social
pressure for me to go out and get one.
What kind of flagged it he gets
you. Oh, you only got you that one.
You know what that one means.
Why don't you fucking shove it
up your twat and dry it out.
Why don't you do that?
Oh, cheese is bill Jesus.
You're going to get that dirty, this
e early. Yes, I am. Listen people,
I have some new information
for you. Um, that has,
that pertains to, that
pertains to the podcast. Um,
I have a new email
address from here on out.
If you want your shit
answered or red on my podcast.
This is the email that you have to send
it to bill@themmpodcast.com all once
again,
Bill B as in bill,
I as an ill l l bill@themmpodcast.com.
That's where you send it. And if you
could help me out in the, in the,
in the subject line just
right. You know, you know,
like is it racist advice?
Overrated. Underrated.
Just helped me out a little bit. Could
you guys, could you do that for me?
For the love of God?
Could you lift your fucking fingers,
put it on the Goddamn keyboard and
helped me up just a little bit. You know,
look at you,
look at you with your large iced coffee.
Just sitting there waiting for
the world to fucking help you out.
Isn't it time you fucking hell.
Let me out. Please send all emails to
bill at the [inaudible] podcast.com.
But the God damn subject
in, in, in the title,
the subject and the subject line,
I put the title,
that's what the fuck I'm trying to
say here. And a the, and by the way,
I keep saying the official website of
the Monday morning podcast and I think I
always forget to say the,
it's www.themmpodcast.com if you'd like
to follow along in your cubicle at work
on a plane, whatever the
fuck you want to do. So I'm,
I'm actually doing this Sunday night,
once again,
I'm going to put it up nice
and early. So, uh, all my, uh,
my 17 fans in Great Britain and my
two fans in the Scandinavian area,
we'll actually get it on Monday morning.
So I don't have to listen to
people fucking bitching at me. Um,
I just went to a,
a Grammy's party. Can you
believe that? Happy me.
Went to a Grammy's party.
I lasted an hour and 20 minutes and um,
I watched the first little number
there, uh, where they had the, the,
the five whaling whores,
you know,
just screech like a bunch of God
damn alley cats. Like how did,
how did that become singing?
It's like they,
they are amazing singers. All
right. The uh, the black chick,
it used to be the fat chick is now
the skinny chick. She's out there,
Waylon shaking her fucking we've around
Christina Aguilera with their fucking
booze face, right in her little
fucking special Horry Mike stand.
She's wailing away.
Then they had was at that Kathy Griffin.
Look and check all of them.
The old Whitney Houston looking broad.
They dragged out all just hitting every
note that they could possibly hit every
12 fucking seconds. They sounded
like a bunch of fucking alley cats.
Whoa.
Oh,
shut up. Oh, Alia
the fuck is wrong with you.
Sing the God damn song.
You know,
you're fucking hold on to it
and then you surprise people.
Then you one unleash shit.
Just get up there fucking screaming like
someone standing on your foot that's
not fucking singing
all five of them.
Somebody can just needed to sit them
down. Oh, and then they're dead.
Fucking emaciated one comes
out, uh, Lady Gaga, right?
You know what? I can't stand.
I hate paint by numbers. Shock.
I can't fucking stand it.
And uh, but it's, it's a,
it's a very smart career choice.
She went,
she was on the red carpet and
she fucking was in, uh, uh,
what the fuck was she in? What is a proper
medical to an ovary? What the fuck was,
she was in a womb.
Her womb is so polluted.
She was in a fucking womb, right? I mean,
that is like fucking
page one of stupid ass,
like a stupid college student film from
like 1963 that was like shocking when
Jim Morrison first started shaving.
All right.
Jesus Christ,
you show up in the fucking thing.
More cues to be in that's
supposed to be artistic.
And everybody's supposed to be,
you know,
and I'm a tell you fucking right now
she's going to be around for 40 fucking
years because people who do
that shit, it's, I dunno,
I dunno
what's what she gonna do next year.
She's going to show up next year and like
an old shoe and then come out dressed
in like a sock, mini skirt, you know,
commenting on the shoeless
people in the fucking world.
And then she goes out and she
sings basically a Madonna Song.
I was at the party and
everyone was singing Madonna
song over it and it and it,
and it meshed perfectly with it.
Express yourself.
Sounded like what she was singing and
then she had all these fucking people
dancing around her.
Right.
And then they have like
that expressionless like a
post apocalyptic makeup on,
you know, that they owe hs was fucking
horrific. And at that point, you know,
at this point I'm in the kitchen and
I'm eating a fucking slice of cheesecake
just for what? What am I
eating it for? You know,
why am I eating?
I'm just doing that so I
can avoid that other shit.
It was horrific.
And I had a real brutal day.
I got a flat tire on my Prius.
Uh,
fuck. It was just for, you know,
it's one of those deals where the,
the front left tire was low.
All right.
And I see that it's low. So I go to a gas
station, I go, I'm like, well that's odd.
So I put air in the tire. This, this
whole fucking thing was my fault, right?
So I put air in the tire and then I just
kind of keep an eye on it and it's went
down a little bit, but not as
much as it had in back of my head.
My brain's going like, dude, what do,
what are you fucking idiot? Take it,
take it over to somebody and check.
You probably got a slow leak.
Maybe they can patch it, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. And I fucking blow it off.
Start driving 70 miles an hour. Just
completely ignoring the fucking thing.
You know, in the back of my head the
entire time I've owned the car, I'm like,
you know bill, you know, okay,
you know this thing has one of those
piece of Shit Jacks that you have to
assemble and then it has
that little hand crank.
Like I'm trying to start like a fucking
model t in the early 19 hundreds.
Right.
I knew that and I knew it was going to
have some half ass fucking that l shape
lug nut thing that you can get
like half a pound of torque on.
And there's no way to get the lug nuts
off cause they fucking put them on with
death think and they don't, they, they
don't stop after it's tight and they go,
oh they fucking, there's no way
to get that thing that you need.
I knew what I needed.
I needed up.
You need a big piece of pipe that
you fit over that piece of shit,
right angle fucking lug nut thing.
And then he can,
you can take them off and I didn't have
it. So whatever. So I went to go do,
uh,
I went to go do the long shot podcasts,
right?
I was doing that fucking thing
and I'm driving out and um,
I, I just hear this noise and my car
wasn't moving smoothly and I was like,
do I have the emergency brake on? What
the fuck's going on? Then I go, Oh God,
oh Jeez. And I pull over and their
am riding on the fucking rim.
So I'm like,
now I,
and I drive a Prius so I'm already on
for spare tires to begin with. Okay.
God knows what the fucking temporary
spare is going to look like. Um,
turns out, it looks like,
you know, when you used,
when you suck on a fucking a
lifesaver, a lifesaver, you know,
and you know when you get to that point,
right when you have it,
just try to keep sucking on it without
breaking it and you get to that point
right before it breaks.
That's,
that's what my temporary spare looks like
and the rim is painted bright yellow.
Okay.
Uh, I have a picture of it, which
will be up on the m M podcast.com. Um,
so anyways, anyway, she, uh,
I pull into a gas station,
which back in the day 12
guys would attack my car.
And what had the fucking thing
changed before I even stopped.
But now you show up,
there's no garage at a gas station anymore
because that entire area is to sell
fucking a whole hose and snowballs
and gum.
So I walk in, I say, yeah, listen, I got
a flat, can you, can you call a tow truck?
He goes, well, I mean I can basically
do what you do. I just call information.
Sounds like I get it. I understand this
wasn't your dream in life, wasn't okay,
I'll go fuck myself. So I go
back out to the hotel, a hotel,
I go out to the fucking, uh,
the God damn parking lot, right?
And immediately, you know, homeless
people start approaching me like, like,
I mean a Zombie movie,
you know, you can't,
you don't notice if you just
go to get gas at a gas station,
you don't realize all the Weirdos.
But when you're fucking sitting there and
you have a flat and there's nowhere to
go, they just didn't come out of
fucking nowhere. And I'm like,
why are they all these fucking homeless
people at a God damn gas station?
I don't, I don't fucking understand it.
They don't have cars if fucking homeless.
Right? Why are they are,
are they at the gas station?
And it turns out I finally figured it out,
especially in La,
which is everybody drives.
There's no one to panhandle to.
You need to get them when they're
getting out of their fucking cars.
So they hang up the god damn gas stations.
These people keep showing up,
you know? Hey Meg, can you give me a
dollar? No, I can't go fuck yourself.
All right. Because you
look like a drunk, sir.
You don't look like a guy who lost
his job and he's down on his luck.
You look like a fucking drunk.
All right. Fucking loser.
Get outta here. Get a job. You're a bum.
You understand me? You're not homeless.
You're a fucking bum. That was
my attitude. And anyways, so, uh,
call up, you know, I
call up the tow truck,
did that Shit,
you know?
Okay.
Then you call them back 20 odd,
20 minutes later they,
Fred that 20 minutes up at
that bap bap APP, right?
Fucking Deco's on 10 minutes was like
an hour and a half. And I was not,
I want to 15 minutes and I was
just sitting there going like,
what did I called at like three
and four, 10 past four. I was like,
if this fucking Douche doesn't
get here by four 15, all right,
I'm calling a friend,
I'm going over to a hardware store and
I'm buying a piece of fucking pipe and
I'm going to, I'm going to figure out
my jack and I'm gonna do this myself.
But fortunately, this fucking guy finally
shows up with his giant Goddamn truck,
which he leaves running,
which is fantastic, right?
So we can just sit there breathing in
the fumes and uh, you know, whatever.
He fucking change the
type, the god damn tire and
this temporary spare is so God damn small.
Um,
I just drove home with it and I parked
the car and I'm like, that's it. I'm done.
I'm dry. I'm driving this car home and
then I'm driving it over to the dealership
tomorrow. That is it. That is how
small this fucking tire is. Like the,
what the fuck light was on,
on my dashboard with a temporary spare.
So, uh, I don't know. That's my
fucking, that was my God damn day.
That's what happened to me today.
People don't really take
me 15 minutes to tell you.
I've got to fucking flat on my car.
Are you really still listening to this?
Are you, were you upset with
me? Um, somebody sent me
this article, actually the,
the, uh, the person who
runs the m m podcast.com,
the official podcast page of the Monday
morning podcast, uh, sent me this,
this article here.
Um,
it's called the day of the lout l
o u t from the Los Angeles Times,
and it's written,
um,
bias actually by some guy,
believe it or not.
And it says unsophisticated,
lazy,
misogynistic males may be the primary
model for today's young American men.
Uh,
and I'm sitting there going,
where the fuck is this guy seeing this?
Because all I see is a bunch of
pussy whipped fags, you know.
All right.
Since the way he says,
if you've seen a beer commercial the last
two years and how can you avoid them?
Well, you could read,
you could Tivo shows.
See Right off the bat,
this guy's a do.
She's trashing men and now he has
problems with beer commercials.
How could you avoid them? I mean really.
Um, he says, you know, the tight,
he's,
he's a 20 or 30 something,
sort of a slacker with a beautiful and
adoring girlfriend who just can't seem to
prize attention away from his suds.
She expresses ardor.
He looks ardently at his mug or can
of beer. I don't know what art means.
I don't even know if I'm pronouncing that
correctly. She wants to talk romance.
He wants to talk anything.
But she gets exasperated.
He snuggles obviously with his
beer and she departs in a huff.
Most Martin takes on manhood say that
guys will do anything to bed a woman.
But this is a new kind of man.
And He seems to be everywhere these days,
not just on beer commercials,
but in movies, on TV,
on hundreds of morning radio shows and
in bestselling books to the point where
he's generating a culture
of new masculinity.
He may even be the primary model
for young manhood in America today.
All right?
This guy has clearly decided to just
completely ignore how much women are
fucking pandered to and how you can make
a guy look like an absolute retard in
any commercial. They always
make the, for the most part,
so many commercials make the guide
look like the moron. You know,
I'm not saying 100%, but can't they have
a couple ones where the guy is a dick?
I'm not saying in, in every, in
every commercial, every TV show,
the guy's got to be cool and he should
act like he doesn't give a shit about his
wife.
But I mean,
yeah,
I dunno if I should legally
be saying this, but, uh,
there there's three things that recently
had, fuck, can I put this, uh,
show ideas, pilots that are
being made out here in Hollywood.
You want to hear him? Fuck it. Who
gives a shit? Okay. One of them was a,
the idea was for a guy who's the audition
was to play a guy who actually speaks
his mind,
but the reason why he speaks his mind is
because he got hit on the head and had
a fucking aneurysm and he almost died.
So then they're thinking,
is this some weird side effect that
a man is actually speaking as mine?
I swear to God,
this is the TV show that they're going
to put millions of dollars behind and a,
and this is how he speaks his mind
in the pilot. He actually, uh,
I, I might get in trouble if
I see what the material is.
He makes a comment about how
big the girls asses, you know,
but of course he likes it. He
likes it. Her ass is big. So it's,
it's self serving to
women, you know? Yeah.
It's basically say, yeah, it's
great that now that we're married,
you've become a dumpy fat.
Fuck sweetheart.
I'm speaking my mind.
Totally pandering to the broads.
Then there's another show
that's in development. I
guess I can talk about this.
It's in fucking development. It's not
a God damn secret. This isn't, this is,
I swear to God, this is the
premise of the show. Uh,
two guys realize that
it's a woman's world.
So they decide to dress as women to get
jobs at a pharmacy and through dressing
like women, they become
better men. I swear to God.
All right. And this is, I got
all of these auditions in a week.
I said no to all of these. All right?
Because I would, I would become a,
I would become an alcoholic. I don't
give a, I don't need, I don't need that.
All right. I'm already a fuck up.
I can, there's no fucking way.
And then the last one was a guy
who is in the shadow of his spouse,
uh,
his,
his famous spouse and get subset because
he's always teased that he's the wife
in the relationship.
And the guy's first name is
Gail could go either way,
like gale sayers.
Uh,
yeah. So I don't know what the
fuck this is bitching about.
And there's plenty of those.
There's all those beer commercials
where the women are going like, yeah,
well I'll tell you what's a good beer
when you take your skirt off your half a
fucking pussy,
right?
All those ones and the guys wearing the
tight jeans and looking like Douche bags
and having sunglasses on.
So this guy just chose to look at
this very small. This is like a guy,
this Guy Neil.
I bet he got the shit kicked out of him
in high school by guys like this. I mean,
what kind of a guy really gets annoyed?
Okay.
Buy Beer commercials.
Really? Are they really dumb?
Do they really fucking appeal to
the lowest common denominator?
Of course they do. You fucking moron.
You want some art? Go rent a good movie.
Well I think, oh, what is he like,
like reminiscing back in the day
when they had good beer commercials,
quality beer, commercial, sweat.
When they had those fucking
lizards talking to each other.
I Dunno
Neal Gabler go fuck yourself.
You guys,
we wouldn't be trying to get laid this
week so that way you had to write that.
Louts. Um, so anyways,
did that go anywhere?
Has This podcast gone anywhere to
22 fucking minutes in Jesus? Oh,
fucking Jesus. Um, what's actually,
let's, let's read some things here.
Yeah. Bill, that, that'll make it better
if you actually start to read, you know,
it was funny. It was, I
sat there, it was at that,
that God damn my Grammy Party and I was
trashing lady Gaga knowing in the back
of my head it was annoying
the shit out of my girlfriend.
She absolutely hates my
behavior when I go to parties.
She can't stand it. She thinks I'm anti
social and she thinks, when I say things,
I just say douchey things.
MMM.
I Dunno what it is. She, someone
who kind of goes, I don't,
I can't say she goes along, I don't know
what the fuck it is, but like, yeah.
MMM.
She's not happy with me right now.
She doesn't like that.
I made fun of Lady Gaga who was
evidently singing express yourself.
I Dunno.
What the fuck was I supposed to
do? I walked in there. I just,
I immediately didn't feel comfortable.
I just, I dunno. All right,
let's plow ahead here.
Um, how about some advice?
I haven't done one of these in a while
when I give something my bed. Oh,
here's a guy bitching about a two
drink minimums at comedy clubs.
Says a bilge. Jimmy Norton
is my favorite comic. Um,
he's getting ready to go on right
now at the Melrose Improv. Yeah,
Jim Norton played the Improv right here
in Melrose, right here in Los Angeles,
um, Saturday night. So his
favorite comedian is Jimmy Norton.
And uh, he says, I guess he's writing
this as the show's about ready to happen.
He says he's ready to go on right now
at the Melrose improv Saturday night.
Guess who's not there?
Not just me,
but probably 50 other assholes that love
him and we could, would kill to see him.
I know it's not Jimmy's fault. Uh,
it's not any of the performer's fault,
but are any of these cock sucking
club owners aware that the economy,
that the economy is in the
fucking toilet right now? No Sir.
I'm sure they have no idea considering
when the economy goes into the toilet,
one of the first things people
cut out his entertainment. Yeah,
I'm sure they're completely
immune to the economy economy.
Sorry,
my voice is cracking.
He said I've skipped most of the handful
of live type events I've wanted to see
for the last six months or so because
of this exorbitantly priced shit.
How can these clubs
justify selling the place,
selling the place out with $25 tickets
to see the guy then charge their two
drink minimum with their $8 beers,
$6 bottle waters and $10 mixed strengths.
So when all is said and done,
you've spent like $40 or more to see a
comic who can afford that kind of shit.
I don't know sir.
With a paper route,
you could really complaining that
it costs 40 fucking dollars. Sir.
This is how it works.
Do you know how you have expenses in life?
Club owners also have expenses.
They have to pay the comedian.
All right.
Okay.
They have to pay taxes.
They have to pay to get a liquor license.
They have to pay all of that shit and
then they have to pay their mortgages and
all of that type of stuff.
And the reason why they have a two drink
minimum is because tight fucks would go
there and just order waters and they
wouldn't make any money and they would go
out of business.
All right,
now I'm not mocking you because you can't
afford $40 I guess I kind of made of
it, but what the fuck, sir?
$40 how much does it cost to go to a
football game? Cost 20 bucks to park.
All right to go down and see the great
Jimmy Norton for $4 $40 you're going to
fucking complain about that because
you got to buy a couple of $10 Shirley
temples, you know, you know
what your problem is, Sarah?
I don't think you have
your priorities straight.
You don't look around your apartment,
you know?
Okay.
What do you got? You had to get a George
Foreman grill. How much did that cost?
You know, does it really work? You know,
cooks chicken and fucking eight minutes,
you know, how does that
taste? Was that worth it?
You ever see fucking George Foreman's
house? She's got a key. So fucking rich.
He named all his kids the same goddamn
name. That's how fucking Richie is.
Like he doesn't even give a fuck that
that he'd do something like that. Sorry.
You're way out of line complaining about
that. Okay. You know what you sound like,
you sound like all these kids today who
go on Youtube and they get upset when a
video gets taken down these fuck
goddamn copyright conch looks like.
They don't seem to understand
that things cost money.
So you have to charge for them.
And when you put up hundreds of thousands
of dollars to produce a film or saw a
music or an album that if people just take
it and they put it on fucking youtube,
you don't get your money back.
You know? So there you go. Sir.
Believer in a, not a comedy
club, it costs money.
So run a comedy club and not to mention
sometimes they give comedians guarantees
like no matter if five people show up a
500 we still have to pay you this amount
of money. And then when five people
show up, they lose their goddamn shirts.
It's not like they're making tons of
fucking money every God damn weekend.
There's a lot of shit that goes into
it. And uh, like I said, you know,
people are tight fucks and if
you didn't make them buy drinks,
they would just sit there.
They would booze in the parking lot and
then they would just fucking sit there
and the club would go out of business.
So I think 40 to see a one of the
top comp comics in the country,
I think that's pretty God damn
reasonable, eh. Uh, you know,
I don't want to tell you how much
it costs to go to a fucking movie.
At least half that is John Travolta
standing there live dancing for you.
He isn't, I don't know.
Might be in a dick here.
Where did I lose the funny
on this podcast is it's pre,
cause I already did an hour long
podcast for somebody else today.
I think I'm all podcast it
out. All right, let's get to,
is it racist, racist? Um,
this is the new of the new fucking thing
here that everybody seems to like. Uh,
is it racist? Um, Bill, although
I thought, uh, also, uh,
thought I'd share a little game that I
used to play. I like this one right here.
This is a great game. You know,
I play that older Asian game.
Anytime anybody cuts me off in traffic,
uh, somebody says a turnoff. I,
this is a game I like to play.
I turn on the TV and without looking,
I try to guess the race
of the person talking.
I call it the Tony Gwynn game.
Now,
for those of you who aren't sports fans,
Tony Gwynn is African American and he
sounds like a def jam comic imitating a
White Guy.
If you closed your eyes,
you wouldn't even think that you
were listening to a white guy.
You would think you were listening
to a black guy imitating a white guy.
He, he, he talks like
he basically like, yeah,
I was talking to Ted Williams the other
day and he's really big on headache. Dad.
Uh, I'm, I'm not, I can't even
do it. I'm not even doing it.
Well not even doing it justice.
Okay.
And I asked him how to hit the
Ed side out curve ball. Um,
the Tony Gwynn game. Yeah. Cause he is the
wildcard. Do you guys think it's racist?
Like I remember back in the
day when the Oj trial when uh,
someone said they heard some yelling and
it sounded like a black guy and people
tried to say that that was racist and
it's like that is not fucking racist.
You know what I mean? If
you heard somebody on the
other side of a fence going,
ah, that's a petty smart. Right.
Would you be like, that's,
I think that that guy could be Italian.
Sorry for my Hacky fucking Asian
offensive, uh, accent there.
But you know what I mean?
Like if you were to listen to me,
not only would you know I was
a guest that I was a white guy,
you would guess that I was
from the east coast one. Yeah.
Just cause you can guess
who to fuck somebody is,
doesn't mean it's racist. That's like so
much. Somebody who send me an email said,
bill, he goes, you're, you're older.
Asian game is racist as shit.
I'm sorry that that was the
person's entire fucking email.
It's like would call,
can you,
can you elaborate a little
bit so you can enlighten me?
Your game is racist
as shit. Oh, well, you know,
thanks for clearing that up.
I don't know what you're apologizing
for. I hate when people say, I hate that.
That's like that fucking, uh, you
know, you know, I listened to your act.
I didn't like it. You know,
I'm sorry I, but I didn't like,
why are you apologizing? I
hate like that whole, like,
you're assuming that you
fucking hurt my feelings.
I don't give a fuck if you think
my game is racist or not. I know.
What is it?
I don't,
I don't have any bad feelings
towards old people or Asians.
I'm just addressing the fact that most
of the time out here when somebody does
something fucked up,
you know?
Is it racist to say white people
can't dance because we can't.
There are examples.
John Travolta.
I believe I already brought up that man
can dance, but it's not racist if some,
if somebody black told me said,
you know what?
White people cannot fucking dance.
You guys don't have any fucking rhythm.
I when I sit there and that's not racist,
I'm sorry,
but it isn't. Um, you know,
that's something I actually,
that hasn't been brought up in this
whole is it or is it racist, racist, um,
topic that I'm doing here is,
uh,
I think that before you fly off the
fucking handle and get offended,
you have to at least, you know, not
all the time, but 10% of the time,
don't you feel that you kind
of have to own up to the fact
that,
ah,
how do I put this?
It's like when Arabs got upset
after nine 11 when they were,
they were getting searched for no fucking
reason other than the fact that they
were Arab. And that's definitely offensive
is definitely fucking annoying. And,
and all of that type of shit.
But on some level,
don't you feel you have a responsibility
to address the 18 Arabs that fucked it
up for you.
You know,
it's like that white people
can't fucking dance. All right?
Are they can't jump or whatever.
I made,
what am I supposed to do?
You know how offended he is at some point
you've got your kind of gotta like I
is one for you. Let me read, let me read
this shit here. Um, not raise my computer,
goes out a bill.
I can't really use names,
but I have a friend who was a Lineman
for a division one football school.
He has a friend who plays in the
NFL as a wide receiver. He, the,
the wide receiver is also white.
Um,
my friend the Lyman told me that the wide
receiver told him that he's tried out
for four NFL teams.
Two of the four told him his chances of
making the team were not good because he
was white. I've had a few arguments
with people. Uh, is it racist?
Should the NFL should at the NFL teams
even mentioned the fact that he has less
of a, because he's white. Well,
no they shouldn't because eventually
someone's going to sue over that.
But that comes to that point I was making
were you also got to understand where
the stereotype came from, all those
slow fucking white guys, you know,
I mean,
one of the reasons why I think Dan Marino
never won a Superbowl was because of
fucking the Blackledge brothers.
He had two white corn evacs you can't
win a fucking Superbowl with two of them.
Maybe one.
But I don't think he could win.
He could win with too. Right. Am
I nuts? I remember, uh, the, the,
the comic strip in a, in a New
York City. I went down there,
I auditioned in 1990.
I went and asked to audition and the guy
running the club told me I already have
enough white guys and I knew a lot of
comedians who got upset like that going
through. That's fucked up.
He would never say our,
I already have enough black guys
and soak. Well, first of all,
there's only like an eight black guys
working here. So he wouldn't say that.
And uh,
I understood what he meant.
I knew what he meant.
He meant you better have a fucking point
of view because I have enough fucking
suburban white guys that can go on
and for 20 minutes be like, you know,
soup with Bill Clinton, you
know, and table. I mean,
which I knew I put it on once,
you know,
crime is and stuff is all in the papers.
Like he had enough people doing,
I totally understood what he was saying.
He just kind of cut through the fat.
I got enough fucking white comics go
in there and do something different.
All right. I have no use
for you. I understood that.
And the only people who fucking complain,
we're lame ass white comedians.
So what am I saying here? Am I justify?
I didn't want him fucking saying,
I feel like I'm justifying it here. I'm
not, I'm not justifying it, but I also,
I'm just saying you got to tone down the
sensitivity here a little bit. You know?
Right.
Older Asian is not racist as shit.
There's an element of fucking truth to
it and there's no hatred in my heart when
I do it.
I just do it for the laugh.
I don't drive around
screaming about Asian,
an old people saying we need to
get him out of the fucking country.
I've had it up to here with their goddamn
driving. They're ruining this country.
They need these old people need to go
back to what from where they came from.
Um, isn't another one. Uh, so anyways,
build tonight I was watching a TV show
and I saw a commercial for the Crisp for
Chris Rock's Broadway show a,
they never said the show's name and
simply referred to it as the title,
you can't say.
And on the screen,
the second word of the title was black
was blackened out and it read the blank
with the hat. I immediately
thought the n word with the hat.
I was also interested in seeing the show.
So I promptly googled it with no results.
I then went to Chris Rock's only to
find the title to the show was the
motherfucker with the hat.
I proceeded to laugh and then thought of
you and your bid. Is it racist? Racist.
So, uh, was that racist bill?
Okay.
I was on the edge,
but generally thought it was funny.
We'd love to hear your thoughts
and your girlfriends too. Well,
a knee is not here right now.
She's mad because of my behavior
at the grammys at the Grammy Party.
Uh, do I think it's racist? No, that's
what I would've guessed. You know, such,
it's such a big deal is made
out of that word. The title.
You can't say Chris
always does edgy stuff.
That's what I would have gone with.
Okay.
You know,
I'm surprised you can't say the
motherfucker with the hat at this point.
I watched 60 minutes tonight
and Andy Rooney said, God damn.
And they didn't bleep it out.
So do I think it's racist? No,
I think I don't.
A lot of people would think it
was just because you thought the,
the n word fit in there.
But I, I maintain this.
Maybe I'm fucking wrong. You
guys can email me, but I,
I really think it comes what's
in your heart when you, when you,
when you're thinking that, I mean,
you were just thinking all the word.
You can't say the title, you can't
say it's always saying, you know,
the n word white people can't
say. You can't say that. You know?
So I, I, no, I don't think that
that's racist and I have the, and I,
and I would have laughed
too when I've read that.
That was actually the motherfucker with
the hat. So, no, no, I don't. All right,
here we go. Uh, Hey Ben,
here's another one. Hey Bill.
Huge fan of up. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Uh,
anyways, I have, I have, uh, uh,
is, is it racist question at my job,
I work with the guy who's not
really Mexican, but his father is
what, what, so what does that
mean? Because he's not 100%
Mexican because he's had,
that would make him half Mexican.
Okay.
You know,
what are you saying?
He's like a light beer in the Mexican
version of that. Um, so anyways, he's,
he's not really Mexican, but his
father is, uh, he's from Arizona,
but he looks the type,
I don't get any of that.
So he's half Mexican, but he looks
full on Mexican is that's what,
is that what you're saying? I don't
think this one's going to end good.
I'm going to go on out on a limb
here. Uh, were okay friends,
but he can be a huge dick sometimes that
occasionally I say something that could
be considered racist,
like shut up. Beaner uh,
but this one time he was working really
hard and I just walked by and said,
you people always,
you people always working hard for little
wage and he was being a huge Dick that
day. Um, before I said that and
he just laughed and we moved on.
My question is, is it racist to say
those type of things if the guys,
if the guy's being a complete
jack off and deep down you feel,
you feel like it shows them
they're being a dick. Ah, yes.
I do think that's racist.
I think if you just said Shit like that
as the joke and you guys were friends
and you were fucking around, it isn't,
but because of the way you're using it,
like when he's being a Dick,
you feel like it,
it shows them that they're being a dick
by saying something racist to him. Yeah.
You're kind of taking it out of the,
uh,
the joke in arena and I'm going to teach
this guy a lesson and put him in his
place. So, uh, and plus also your,
your fucking kind of naive statements
of he's not really Mexican,
but his father is, but
he looks the part. Yeah.
Yeah. I'd say I'd be in a, you know, in a
bar with you and probably, I don't know,
about 20 minutes. Then you'd say something
that I would be like, you know? Yeah.
I could get, what did you say? Could you
say that? Could you repeat that? You know,
trying to, with the jukebox
noise in the background. Yeah.
But you ever had that in a fucking bar,
you just hanging out.
It happens to me all the time on the
fucking road. Back when I was boozing,
I'd be out there and I would just be a,
I'll tell you one of the weirdest ones
I ever had. I did this bit on, uh,
okay.
Uh, Jamie Foxx laugh a
Palooza thing. Um, Jamie Fox,
by the way, who plays my shit all
the time on his channel, on uh,
on Sirius Xm, the foxhole. I've had more
goddamn people come up to me saying,
I heard you on the Fox hole. I thought you
were funny. That's why I came up to my,
uh, out to your show. So thank you to
everyone over there. Um, but anyways,
so I did this bit and it was a story
that happened to me when I was at,
when I was in Nashville,
Tennessee. I was, uh,
I was drinking in the bar by myself.
God,
that sounds like such a great fucking
idea. 120 days. Then people, oh,
does that sound like a good idea?
Drinking by myself.
I got damn bar at a couple of fucking,
um,
I'm in Nashville, Tennessee
and Tarell Owens, this is like,
I don't know how many fucking years ago,
but he was doing what he always does.
Starts off good with the team, then it
becomes a total fucking cunt. So I said,
I said, something's effective.
Can you believe this fucking guy?
How much goddamn money do you need to
make before you're not a dick? Like,
what the fuck is wrong with this guy?
And uh,
Oh God, it's been so long since
I remember this I the guy,
I'll tell you what the fucking problem
is because the guy's a fucking end.
He just dropped the n word
and
out of fucking note.
And I immediately was just like,
okay.
I immediately though, how
was it? I immediately looked
around, I was like, Oh fuck,
I'm going to get fucking some black dude
is going to punch this guy in the face
through my head, cause I'm standing next
to him like, I'm going to get fucking,
they're gonna think I'm with this
guy. So that, that was, that's right.
This has been a long time since I
told the joke. That was the joke.
So the joke was basically he dropped
the fucking inward. Uh, that's right.
He didn't say what the Aa, he said what
the R and he didn't pull up on the yard.
He fucking stuck the landing.
That's how the joke went.
And I felt like I just wished it was
somewhere I could just act like they show
was some something that I could have done
in that moment to immediately say like,
I didn't know this fucking guy. You know,
I had no idea everything was normal.
We would talking football and out of
nowhere he starts with this clan rally
bullshit. So, uh,
okay.
And I remember too,
like
I didn't roll with what he said and I
forget what I said, but he clearly knew
okay
that I was annoyed by him and then he
tried to fix it real quick and try to say
like, I'm not saying they're all
like that. There are some good ones.
And then it was fuck,
it was like a fucking sick home.
And then five seconds later, some
black dude comes walking in, right.
And then he's like,
oh, hey, how you doing?
He's trying to be over friendly to the
guy in some way to make up for the fact
that he dropped the n word to me.
Yeah.
And the,
and the whole fucking thing was phony.
And then I felt like he was dragging me
into it and I wanted to say to the guy
at that point like,
hey,
why don't you tell that guy some of the
shit you were just saying to me five
seconds ago, you know,
all that classic shit.
When you think of all the funny stuff
you should've said the moment, you know,
20 minutes fucking later. Um,
so anyway, so I basically,
I turned that into a bit and I did
it on the laugh, a Palooza thing.
So like three years later,
I'm in North Carolina
working in this club.
And uh,
afterwards I'm standing there and I'm
talking to this dude who is like the most
stereotypical redneck guy ever.
You know,
just talking lock the edge,
but they or be like if,
if like if someone from the north did
that accent on TV would be considered like
offensive. That's all. Like how fucking
hardcore this guy was. You know, you know,
I was on my tractor the other day and I
was listening to one of my pigs got out
it, how's labs are you
stop? I'm barely catch him.
I mean like telling me stories like that.
Right.
But then he starts
talking about my comedy.
Okay.
And he was really breaking it
down and just talking about
like in a really intelligent
way was breaking the thing down.
I was sticking in my head like this is
why I love doing the road because you
meet all these fucking people,
you have all these preconceived notions.
I'm a fucking looking at this guy.
Like this guy's a God damn hillbilly and
here he is breaking down comedy and my
act in particular
like borderline on the level that
a comedian could. So I was like on,
this is why I love doing the road. This
is why, this is what makes you worldly.
This is how you know it makes you, you,
you stop thinking ignorant shit, you know,
which is hilarious. All the
ignorance, should I say on my pocket,
whatever makes you less ignorant.
So right as I'm having that feel
good moment thinking about this dude,
I forget what the fuck, what the fuck
happened. But then out of nowhere he,
he said he was telling a story.
Oh.
And he actually alluded to the tea
actually brought up the joke that I,
the story that I told about being in
Nashville and then the guy dropping the n
word and he knew why it was funny
and he broke that whole joke down.
He had this really redneck Yat accent
and I was like, look at that. See you.
They're not all fucking racist right then.
I don't know where he starts telling some
fucking story, trying to make me laugh.
And He, and then his punchline,
he'd gotten himself into
some sort of predicament.
And then his punchline was, I was more
nervous than an end war than Mike Tice.
No, I was more nervous than
an n word in a, in a, uh,
in a spelling bee or something.
He dropped the fucking
inward and I remember going
okay.
And I just said out loud to myself
with the fucking music was so loud.
I was just, I was just like,
and then that happened.
So I said to the guy, I got, dude,
you just broke down that fucking joke
where I talked about somebody doing that
and then five minutes later you do it.
And he says,
Hell Yeah,
I love that joke.
Like he still didn't get it and I th
three times I fucking went in trying to
explain to him what the fuck just at,
why would you do that?
And uh, just never fucking dawned
on him. And then I, I just,
uh,
he was talking to me and I just walked
off like mid sentence as he [inaudible]
fabric fear and I just
fucking walked away. Uh, uh,
uh,
what else?
Then I went to the other side of the
bar and I remember there was these four
chicks were dancing on the bar
doing the coyote ugly thing.
And one of them was a fat chick who was
not sexy but was dancing in a very sexy
way. And I remember being annoyed
at her. I was really fucking annoyed
that she had the confidence to do
that. I was like, why? You're horrific.
You should be off the bar doing sit ups.
You should feel shame and you don't.
Yeah.
And I dunno. Normally that would
have made me laugh I guess,
but maybe cause what the fuck happened?
Dove,
I just remember being really annoyed.
Uh,
I don't fucking know. Do you know I
went on, I had such a fucked up week.
I don't even know what that fat chick
just reminded me of something I went to.
I went on a couple's date
to a cheesecake factory. Um,
and in defense they said, look, we
don't have to go there, but you know,
they got kids and shit.
They just picks something quick and
you people know how I feel about the
cheesecake factory. But I was like,
you know, I don't give a fuck.
It's better than Apple Bee's.
I'll go over there. It's,
you know the talking
about going in an hour.
So I go over there and I just want to
tell you guys something just in case,
just in case you don't know the
cheese cake factory fucking sucks.
All right? It's, that is horrible food.
Horrific,
horrible fucking food.
And the reason why I'm saying this is
because every time I fucking walked by one
of them,
it is jam packed with people.
Line out the fucking door.
Everybody holding those little vibrating
things waiting to get called to go into
to to a fucking table, which is exactly
what happened to us. And I went in there,
I ordered the Colby Beef Burger.
I went as high up on the menu as I could
and I still felt like I fucking ate a
part of my God damn dresser just sitting
in my fucking stomach like a Goddamn
old boot.
Horrible fucking food.
Can you people please stop
going to that restaurant?
Sorry. He was telling me tonight
they don't even advertise on TV.
They don't have to people just line.
They just think it's fucking good.
Like Lady Gaga
coming in and that fucking
egg from the morgue show.
You know what's going to kill me is when
people just going to talk about like
how outrageous that was.
You know,
who thinks like that type
of shit is outrageous.
People who fan themselves with
their hands when they begin to cry.
If you ever seen people like that,
when they start getting emotional,
they fan their face.
What the fuck I'm talking about anymore?
Let's get the youtube videos.
At this point.
I'm really in a fucking grumpy ass mood.
I had a bad burger this weekend.
I had a fucking flat tire.
Okay,
got it. God Damn yellow spare goddamn
breath mint for a fucking temporary spare.
This is just a miserable fucking
podcast and I was in a good mood too.
All right, you two videos of
the week. Uh, NFL trick shot,
white quarterback, uh, check
this. These are all on the Mlm,
podcast.com. By the way, I'm this
fucking kid's amazing. You know,
I know a lot of them, you know? Okay.
How many attempts did he make
to make the fucking throw?
But there's a couple where he does like
to three um, tricks all in one take.
Very impressive. But at the
end of the video, oh, okay.
Let me fucking hiccups at the end
of the video. Candy Brita Defense.
Here's another one. This kid, uh, just uh,
if you want to see just a
great fucking story teller. Um,
I don't even know if this
is the name of the video,
but this is Baltimore storyteller.
The fuck this guy tells a story about,
uh,
oh his dad sent him to the corner store,
okay.
For some bread and he has to get by
some gang bangers in this fucking guy.
I watched like three of his videos.
It's just phenomenal.
Just a phenomenal fucking storyteller.
I love telling stories and I nothing
more like then listen to a great
storytellers.
This kid's great.
So check that out and check out all those
other videos. A midget wrestler flying.
All right? If you ever wanted
to see a midget in a, uh,
dressed up like a baby gorilla,
get kicked by a fat bald guy,
I believe the guy's bald.
And then go flying ass over tea
kettle in land on another wrestler.
This is the video for you
and a funny drum video.
I love this video because the
guy's fucking hilarious. Uh,
English seems to be his third language.
I put that on the high hat that they
high had that one, the one tote tray.
Okay. And uh, and no one told Trey. Okay,
that's literally, this is how this
guy fucking gives the the drum lesson.
But then he proceeds to play
this fucking sick drum groove,
which I still can't fucking play.
Um, so the guys like awesome.
It's just a pharmacist like a
second or third language. Um, oh,
and if you want to see another
great wrestling, just horrific.
The WCW dungeon of doom, full segment.
I don't know who wrote this shit.
Um, but it is horrific in a
phenomenal fucking way. Uh,
what else do I got in here?
Oh, here's some advice.
Somebody wants a bill. My girlfriend
looks like a centerfold. Good for you.
She's blind.
She has a beautiful face,
a tiny waist in giant cans.
I have outdone myself.
Well, what the fuck, man? Don't you
sell yourself short? Maybe you're,
maybe you're a, you're a
stud. So he says, however,
having a girlfriend of such
caliber as you might imagine,
comes with its share of problems.
Ooh, Jesus. Here we go. Like,
uh, like your good self.
I battle my battle,
keeping my temper under control at
times and particularly struggle when my
girlfriend and I go out in
public together. In short,
the amount of male attention
she gets is ridiculous.
And at times it's infuriating.
Have you ever found you found yourself
out with a girl and notice that every man
within a three mile radius from the
sweaty 22 year old walking boner to the
porky,
sexually frustrated father of three is
blatantly staring at her tits in her ass.
Um, I've always been of the opinion
that if a girl is obviously with a guy,
whether you know him or not,
it's a gentleman's code not to have a
staring contest with there with her,
with her a ring piece.
I don't know what that means.
What's that looking at her pussy. I have
no idea. This guys from Australia. Um,
if a girl is alone or with girlfriend,
sure. Objectify the shit out of her.
But I think if a girl is holding hands
with their boyfriend and you make it
obvious that your helmet is pressing
against the inside of your front Zipper,
then you're a cunt. Um, nothing
serious has happened yet,
but the weather is getting warmer.
The outfits are getting smaller and I'm
concerned I'm going to wind up with,
I'm going to wind up with some perverts
blood and quite possibly come on my
hands all for now. Um, all right.
All right. This is a tricky
situation, sir. You know,
is a very tricky situation.
You know,
there's a price you pay for everything.
All right?
You're the one who has his centerfold
fucking girlfriend with a great ass and
Nice set of fucking tits and
a, you just, you just have to
this, this, this is, this
is how I look at this shit.
As long as you're,
a woman isn't going around trying to
get attention if she's just fucking
standing there and she's so goddamn
stunning that men are looking at her,
but you know, she's not, Ooh,
I dropped my lipstick and then slowly
bending over at the waist while looking
over her shoulder. Um,
if she's doing that,
I can tell you right now a banger
another couple of times and then fucking
dumper because she's going to be an
absolute fucking nightmare and a,
and you don't need that in your life.
Okay.
But if she's just a
stunningly gorgeous woman, um,
you, that kind of comes with it. And, uh,
if you lose your fucking temper
and you start acting like a maniac,
that's a great way to eventually
annoy the shit out of her.
And because she can't help
it. Like I said, if she's
not trying to get attention,
she can't help it, that
she's gorgeous. And, uh,
if you then,
it's in this weird way,
you're giving her shit for being herself,
which is not fun for anybody and then
you're going to have a problem. So.
Okay.
Um, I don't know how to, if you
know what it's like, it's like a,
it's like when I whore myself out at
the end of my shows and I sell DVDs.
All right? I don't have to do that,
but I choose to do it and I'm standing.
It was a choice I fucking made.
And then I stand there and what's
going to happen? I answered this. Yeah.
This is one of these podcast questions.
All right.
Eventually somebody is going to come up
and they're going to fucking insult me.
He's telling me they didn't
like my act. Tell me. Uh,
they didn't think I was as funny as when
they saw me on TV and I can't get mad
because it's my fucking fault for
standing there like an asshole.
Just, you know, I, I put myself on the
dunking store and I got to admit, sir, if,
if you're, if this, if your girl
is the way that you describe her,
you just have to accept that it's,
it's par for the course and uh,
just give yourself a little halftime
speech before you go up. You know,
I'm not going to lose my shit. Um, but
if it is overt,
uh,
there has to be a way that you can fucking
address it without pissing her off,
without, you know, you also don't
want to get into a fucking fight. Um,
I dunno. Just say, hey buddy can, can
you eliminate it to like, you know,
five second shifts of staring at her tea.
I can't say tits.
Okay.
Uh, I don't know what you do.
Do that. That's a rough one.
That's a rough run. They,
man,
that takes me back to being
Jesus Christ. I was like 21
years old. I went on this,
I went out on a date with this girl who
was well out of my fucking league just
because I didn't have the
confidence to fucking be with her,
you know what I mean?
MMM.
Beautiful Girl.
And I went out with her and I noticed he
just kept looking around the restaurant
to see who was looking at her. And I
remembered it annoyed the shit out of me,
but I, I, I didn't have any
experience with beautiful women,
so I just sort of accepted it. And, um,
but I never went out with her again.
It just, it drove it. I saw, I tapped
out somewhere through the fucking dinner.
Even back then, I was an angry
son of a bitch. I was like,
let me get this straight.
I'm buying you fucking dinner and
you're looking around to see who's Elsa
staring at your tits.
Um, yeah, you're a cunt.
Good looking cunt. But uh, nonetheless,
someday those looks are going to be gone
and I'm just going to be left with the
cunt.
You know who's going to be a psycho cunt
because you're an attention whore and
when the attention goes away,
you're going to be like some celebrity
who fell off the fucking math.
Fuck this bitch. Fuck this. You know?
And that was the end of that shit that
is podcast is fucking horrific. Jeez,
I don't even get going,
man. You know what it is.
I had a flat tire today and I
think that that's, that's been,
that's a good symbol. Uh, this whole
podcast, I've just been riding on the rim
Af. Fuck. I got to start my day tomorrow
down at the God damn dealership.
It was fucking Douche bags. They've got
everything. It's all wrapped up. You know,
if you do anything to you,
God damn car.
If I go down to the God damn auto zone
and I get new wiper blades, I think that,
I think that cancels out my warranty.
He's fucking cunts. Um, so anyways,
this was the lane podcast for this week.
I know it had its moments.
Who's getting no,
it started off wealth when I was
talking about those whaling horse. Um,
I actually had a nice little
show biz moment. A friend
of mine got me tickets to,
uh,
um,
the roots do this pre grammy jam where
they're just the house band and like
fucking,
I dunno,
20 or 30 of the most
legendary insane acts ever.
Just come on stage and start singing songs
with them and doing fucking whatever.
And somebody got me a ticket,
uh, you know, hanging out,
you know, somehow I got in there
and uh, it was fucking unbelievable.
I think I came home that
night and I downloaded like
probably about $70 worth of
music, just the, the level of talent that
was that there. And I'm an old guy now,
so I don't know who the fuck,
I don't know who the fuck.
And if Neil was telling me who everybody
was, she was freaking the fuck out.
Oh my God, that's fucking
Mc. So, and I have no,
I don't know who the fuck they are.
You know what I tapped when they
stopped showing videos on MTV?
I kind of liked that
last wave. Jay Z, m. And.
M.
Mmm.
Was there any rock like by
then it was all that emo shit,
so I couldn't relate to any of that.
Yeah.
What does that fucking Goddamn
wining song about not giving up?
Woo.
They actually play that
at sporting events.
It sounds like a man crying.
I don't know.
I know he's saying we will be
victorious, but like just, it just,
it could have been a better line read,
you know,
all that shit. That's when I tapped
out all that. My Chemical Romance. Uh,
could I have another Kleenex please?
Whatever the fucking name is.
Other bands where I just,
uh,
I don't know. Everybody just
sounded like they were crying.
I couldn't handle it.
You sex is on fire.
That guy fucking crying through all his
songs. How does that fucking song go?
Rami. The Cure. That's how the
guy in the cure used to sing.
Oh,
always love you.
Um,
yeah, I'm not into that ship. I'm
sorry. Was that, that was that annoying?
Was that as annoying as it just
sounded in my fucking is what?
The music is fucking annoying.
So I didn't know who anybody was,
but uh,
you know, it was amazing.
It was booker t came out.
What didn't even from
booker t and the mgs,
I didn't even know the fucking dude was
still alive and it was such like a Paris
Hilton. Oh my God, am my God.
That's hot kind of fucking crowd.
Okay.
That, uh, that they had no
fucking idea who the guy was.
Oh,
my favorite performer of the night
was a chuck Brown, came out and sang,
busted loose,
and he was the shit.
He came out on a leather and on leather
fucking outfit with the fucking pimp hat.
He sang the shit out of the song
with the roots in the background.
Okay.
And the roots of fucking unbelievable.
And it for guitarists out there,
everybody knows quest is to shit.
Okay.
But as underrated,
Kirk Douglas Diff fucking guitarist.
Okay.
That dude is fucking insane.
I'm talking John, the ground
level plant, they just fucking,
everybody in that band is just,
they're insane.
Okay.
And a fortunate, we were sitting close
enough that I was just awesome. Like,
you know me,
I'm like a fucking geek for that shit.
Like I wish I could be if I didn't do
this. I wish I could be a, so I like,
I think like anybody,
you can do that stuff as I've trashed
half the people on the grammys,
you know what I'm saying? But like
musicians, people playing instruments,
I'm absolutely fucking blown away by him.
And just being close enough to
watch somebody take a solo and just,
you could just see just
going off the top of,
they just feeling it and just
doing it and coming out of it.
And then just fucking looking back at
the drummer like, all right, let's,
let's go back into this next part of it.
And everybody seamlessly goes into it.
You know, anybody's ever
played like a fucking garage
band, you know, and, and just,
you know, had the courage to make a tape
and you hear how fucking awful you are.
They actually hear live music and they
played for like three fucking hours.
I ended up leaving.
I was so god damn old.
Like I'm at the age now where if I
stand up too long, my back hurts.
Like my lower fucking back, my feet
hurt. It's, it's fucking, it's terrible.
I've got to come home and sit
in a Goddamn Tba Epson salt.
But anyways,
uh,
I downloaded a bunch of Chuck Brown Shit,
a couple other rappers.
I download it. I don't have my
iTunes open right now. I don't even,
I don't know who the fuck they were.
Uh, but it's kind of funny rappers now,
they have that odd thing where they,
they're wearing skinny tight jeans,
which I never thought would
come back into style again yet.
They're still hanging off their fucking
ass, which drives me up the Goddamn wall.
Fuck. Pull 'em up. Um, anyways,
that's the podcast for this week. Oh,
I am going to be in, I have to a
magnificent theater dates this,
uh, this this fucking week
because I'm God damn big shot.
Let me see if I can open my website here
and let you know where the hell these
things are. This really isn't even
technically the podcasts anymore.
This is just the outtakes.
Um,
I am going to be at the Tarrytown
music hall in Tarrytown,
New York, and uh, it's February
17th, which is a Thursday.
Friday, I'm going to be at the count
Basie theater in Red Bank, New Jersey.
So come one, come all.
I have a brand new hour,
his shit and I got a new killer fucking
15 minutes, then I'm absolutely loving.
And every time I do it, it becomes
a couple more minutes. You know,
one of those bits started
with like four minutes.
I just keep fucking elaborating and,
uh, uh, planning on having a great time.
So, uh, hope all you guys can come out to
that, uh, for people who live in Florida,
um, people always talking about that. Oh
yeah. I got some fucking gigs here, man.
Places I don't usually play.
I have,
I'm playing the new World Symphony and um,
symphony symphony theater on the
4th of March, Miami Beach, Florida,
the Tower Theater and Philadelphia
on April 9th and the day,
either the day before that
or the day after that,
I just added a date in Maryland
too. I'm going to put the
date up, uh, tomorrow. Uh,
it gets all solidified and
uh, oh, actually outside of,
yeah, outside of Baltimore,
I have a Gig and uh,
the PAPP's theater in Milwaukee,
Wisconsin on April 22nd,
April 23rd,
I'm at the Royal Oak Music Theater
in Detroit, Michigan. And uh,
also I added, um, I just
put another date up.
Jimmy Norton,
a antisocial tour,
the Miami Heat of comedy shows.
It's a stars. Jimmy Norton,
Jim Brewer,
Dave Attell.
And myself and we're going to be at
the Foxwoods casino and Masha Taka a
Connecticut on, uh, April 30th. Um,
anybody in the New England
area, a tristate area. You
got to come up for that one.
I'm going to tell you right now,
uh,
I worked with those guys.
They're fucking,
all of them are at the top of the
fucking game. And I'm telling you,
we did three shows when I was
in Atlantic City and you know,
you know it as Comedians, we don't watch
standup. We just don't after a while.
But I stood on the side wall,
watched all of them. Um,
I just, it just the fucking phenomenal.
So please come out to those shows.
That's it. That's the podcast for this
week. You guys all have a good week. Uh,
I don't know what else to tell Ya.
Fuck.
I forgot to talk about the
Bruins Canadians game to
just see that with all the
old school fighting in the goal
scoring was like fucking 27 to 26,
I think was the final score
with all the fighting.
And I want to know Montreal Canadians.
What the fuck happened? He had team,
I'm not giving you shit about losing
a game was only one fucking game.
But I mean,
you guys always had a tough guy all
the way back to fucking John Cordic,
Chris Nilan, George low, rocky had, that
guy was the toughest guy in the league.
Why did you guys, all
you had was, you know,
I know the Bruins kicked the
shit out of you guys, but
I'm not an idiot. We, we, we,
we beat up a bunch of gold scores. I
felt bad for that last guy. Jesus Christ.
He took like 20 upper cuts to the face
and somehow ended up with two giant paper
cuts. Um, Google it, man. Maybe I'll,
I'll have that youtube video also
on the [inaudible] podcast.com. Uh,
but I'm telling you right now,
if you're a fan of fighting and hockey
watched the game on March 8th when the
Bruins and the Canadians play again,
because I'm a tell you right now,
the Canadians are not going to sit
back and take that fucking physical ass
kicking that they took. I, and I cannot,
I can't wait to see the absolute fucking
animals that they're going to bring up
for that game.
You know,
whatever has a lower
beyond thunder bay is what I'm guessing
what they're going to bring up.
Just like some old school fucking guy,
one of those white guys who has
like an afro in a porno mustache.
I'm thinking they're going to bring up
a couple of those guys and it's going to
be, it's going to be fucking insane. I
hope it is. I hope it doesn't fucking,
not live up to the hype. Um,
all right. That's it. I'm done.
Okay. I've had a long fucking, all right.
And I apologize to anybody out there
who aspires to be a whaling whore at the
grammys. You know, I'm just, you
know, I'm not saying that those,
those whaling whores, they're
not horse, but you know,
I, I don't under, I fucking,
yeah,
don't understand that kind of singing.
It's, you're not singing, you're wailing.
Okay.
All right.
Just seeing the fucking song,
you know,
and then, and then fucking what's her
face? So booze, booze, face there.
She always gets that her son and a voice.
No.
Ugh.
She's got that pasty bloated booze face.
And then just in case you miss it,
she puts that red lipstick
and I'm in the middle.
Yeah.
Don't you just want to grab Christina
by both the big jobs, you know?
Okay.
She got a man's haircut. She could
do like the Winston Churchill Story.
I've been, I've actually, this is just,
this is totally like extra time on doing,
on the podcast to try and get something
funny in this fucking thing this week.
I noticed the other day.
MMM.
You know,
to will to people who really look alike
is Richard Simmons and the lead singer
of the Scorpions.
You notice that they have the
exact same awful fucking hair.
They're going bald in the exact
same fucking way. You know?
Did I just do an awful fucking eighties
joke? Were they separated at birth?
Have you ever seen them
together? Oh, Bill.
Quit by your fucking behind.
All right. This is it.
How long can you guys
still listen to this shit?
How long are you gonna sit
there and torture yourself?
This is like a comedian does not get off
the fucking stage as people look slowly
walking out of the Goddamn club.
I'm still here.
How empty or your lives shut it off.
Um,
oh fuck. You know what? I forgot to play.
I asked somebody from England to,
to,
I wanted to hear a cozy
smug cunts in the unit.
Militia accent. Here it goes. You want
to hear it? Here it is. Here it is.
This is all the way from my fucking
people over and hang. Hang on.
What the fuck just happened? I'm
gonna play it again. Here comes,
how does he smile? Cows. He smug.
Can't every a couple of cows he smug
consists of fucking love that all right.
There you go. That's the podcast for this
week. I apologize for the meandering.
Okay.
I apologize. Is from for my excuses.
I went real Peyton manning this week,
didn't I? We had protection issues.
I had a flat tire, you know,
that was a real bitch this week. Um,
whatever. I'll make it up next week. Okay?
They can't all be gems.
All right?
Okay.
Everybody has a bad fucking day,
so don't take it out on me.
I apologize to all the whaling horse
out there. I said that. All right.
I don't know how to get off stage
this week. All right, that's it.
Have a great day. What could we go?
Fuck yourselves? Don't take any shit.
Talk to you next Monday.
See you.